hi everyone in this video I'm going to
discuss the technical details of the
wave function collapse algorithm and the
very closely related model synthesis
I'll also discuss what features of these
algorithms I'm looking for in my
projects
in my last video I gave an overview of
wave function collapse and my interest
in using it to generate procedural
Terrain
it might be helpful to watch that one
first
both wave function collapse and model
synthesis are about constraint
satisfaction
they're used to generate some solution
for a texture or a model given known
constraints about how pieces fit
together
constraints come up quite a bit in games
especially puzzle games
Sudoku makes a game out of constraint
satisfaction each row and column contain
the numbers 1 through 9 with each number
appearing only once
additionally all the smaller grids also
contain the numbers 1 to 9.
you're given some initially collapsed
cells the domains of the remaining cells
contain all possible numbers
your job is then to collapse these cells
in a way that satisfies all constraints
a good first step is to reduce each
cell's domain using the information you
currently have
this took me a little while until I
realized there's actually a button right
here that does it for me
from there you can start collapsing
cells and use that information to
further reduce domains
I'm uh I'm not going to solve this whole
thing on this channel we don't do
constraint solving we make programs to
do constraint solving
there's another one Minesweeper is
another game that involves constraints
you're given a grid of cells that may
contain mines initially you only know
how many minds are present but not where
they are
clicking on a hopefully empty cell or
reveal its contents and will also reveal
all connected empty cells
the cells with numbers show a constraint
this number indicates how many minds are
found in adjacent cells
with this information you can start to
determine which cells contain mines
I'm pretty sure this top cell doesn't
contain a mine
and maybe this one doesn't either oh
if you're like me when I was a kid I
used to play this on Ultra easy mode on
a big grid with just a few mines
so one click and hey I'm so good at this
some of you know what I'm talking about
and of course Wordle also involves
constraints
after a guess you get information on
correct and incorrect letters as well as
correct and incorrect positions
personally I like the constraint solving
part of Wordle and its Big Brother
cordial but not the word part itself
words for me not so good
so constraint programming can be used to
deliberately make constraint based
puzzle games or to solve problems that
just happen to involve constraints any
problem that can be conceptualized in
terms of constraints might be a good fit
for a constraint programming solution
here's my current real life constraint
problem I have too many turtles
they're part of a behavior research
project and while they're very cute they
can also be a lot of work
these sliders get along well in their
babies as long as other requirements are
met
however as they get older they have more
and more housing constraints
they're really best housed individually
or in very small groups since there are
major constraints on cohabitation
some are too aggressive to live with
others
all turtles in a group also need to be
the same size
even temperament can be an issue
bold and shy individuals don't mix well
the more outgoing turtles will have
better access to food and basking sites
while I'm not intending to program a
constraint solver to help me plan new
enclosures
I do find myself thinking about this
problem and others in terms of
constraints
of course in this case the best solution
is more ponds
[Music]
let's talk about some more realistic
applications of constraint solving
I found several papers using constraint
programming to plan work schedules that
makes me think about Colony management
games like rimworld this one is on how
cognitive dissonance a psychological
phenomena can be modeled by a constraint
satisfaction neural network I really
like the intersection of these topics so
I'm gonna have to read more into this
one also check out this dissonant sign I
found near my hometown please keep your
pets on leash in designated areas but
also don't have them
this paper discusses a constraint-based
system to design novel benzonoid
chemicals this paper talks about a
procedural poetry generator here's one
of the poems they generated
music Wells acts and practices
traditionalism hymns her devoted racing
spent in her court and then vivaciously
directly a Universe She disappears and
Adam in the seasons of record
and finally this was one of my favorite
papers the author wanted to use
constraint programming to find new
musical scales there's actually some
science and math behind music so I
really appreciated this attempt to
leverage the technical side of music to
create something new
of course this has to be heard to be
appreciated this samples from a 19 note
chromatic scale our standard octave is
12 notes
foreign
[Music]
it's interesting different but not
altogether Ben
okay I suppose it's time to get back on
topic there are links to papers and
things in the description
wave function collapse and model
synthesis also fall under constraint
programming
unlike many puzzle games where the goal
is often to find the one correct
solution with wave function collapse and
model synthesis the goal is to create
any solution that satisfies the
constraints
both wave function collapse and model
synthesis also draw inspiration from the
texture synthesis family of algorithms
[Music]
the classic methods were based on
deliberately crafted algorithms the
animation here shows one technique
called image quilting
more recent methods take a neural
network approach
they can produce some amazing results
but are a little out of scope for this
video
and for the moment my skill set
wave function collapse and model
synthesis build upon both constraint
programming and the earlier texture
synthesis methods
Paul Merrell's model synthesis was the
first the two algorithms it was Paul's
PhD dissertation project and was
published in 2007 with a few more papers
released in the following years texture
synthesis works really well except when
it doesn't
one of Paul's goals was to improve on
some of these areas
at the time Paul was developing model
synthesis
some of the early taxosynthesis
algorithms had issues with rigid
structures
they were also not well suited for 3D
generation
Paul recognized that many natural and
artificial objects consist of similar
self-repeating components
and perhaps by breaking down objects
into these components instead of just
thinking about pixels
we can use these components to
procedurally generate new objects in 2D
or 3D
here are a few more examples from Paul's
dissertation
can you tell how things are built from
components
check out Paul's website for more
here's the basic workflow of model
synthesis
first unique components and knowledge of
how they fit together
in other words modules and constraints
they can be derived from an input or
created manually
second select a cell to collapse
third assign the cell a random module
from its current domain the modules can
be given weights to make some more
likely to be selected
fourth use the constraints of the newly
assigned module to reduce the domains of
adjacent cells and propagate these
constraints as far as they will reach
now just repeat steps 2 3 and 4 until
all cells have been assigned
if you watched my last video you might
recognize this is the method used by
wave function collapse that is not a
mistake
at this level they're the same algorithm
[Music]
wave function collapse was released in
2016.
it's heavily influenced by model
synthesis
the name takes some inspiration from
quantum mechanics I realize this is
controversial so I'm staying out of it
feel free to have more epic debates in
the comments All of You are winners to
me you might notice model synthesis
focused more on 3D while wave function
collapse focus more on 2D
both methods can be applied to graphs of
any dimensions
that means both support all sorts of
grids in 2D or 3D
square and Cube grids are common but
irregular grids like in townscaper are
fine too
if you have a 4D application I'd love to
hear about it
synthesis and wave function collapse
differ
isn't how they implement the steps I
mentioned earlier
let's start by discussing how the
modules and constraints are created
the original method described by Paul is
called discrete model synthesis no not
this discrete this discrete
here a model is broken down into
discrete pieces
I follow this General method except that
I create my discrete modules by hand in
blender
by the way for the rest of the video I'm
using a simplified version of kanos
Chen's tile set for demonstrations
see the description for a link to their
assets
all also created another method called
continuous model synthesis
I'll be honest this is some fancy code
magic and not a path I'm prepared to go
down
the basic idea is to place vertices
edges and faces in continuous space
instead of placing fixed modules in a
discrete grid
Paul does some impressive stuff with it
but also notes limitations
I don't think I've seen this implemented
outside his dissertation
check out some of his materials for more
details for now we will consider this a
separate algorithm
wave function collapse uses a method
very similar to discrete model synthesis
called the simple tiled method
however it's better known for the
overlapping method which is one of the
novel additions
with discrete model synthesis and simple
tiled wave function collapse it's
possible to create matches for each
module manually which is currently my
preferred technique
however the overlapping method requires
a sample to analyze let's start with
this simple sample note the arrangement
of grasses and bushes
from the sample we can determine which
tiles fit together and how frequently
each tile occurs if we only consider
what tile is adjacent to other tiles we
are essentially doing discrete model
synthesis or simple tiled wave function
collapse the results look similar to the
input but don't share the specific tile
Arrangements the bush patterns from the
sample may not appear in the result
now let's expand the sample analysis to
consider each two by two square of tiles
we're changing from the simple tiled to
overlapping method
the output now contains various two by
two patterns observed in the input
though in this case it doesn't seem
enough for a good resemblance
when using a three by three analysis
the patterns are much more apparent
and with a 4x4 the input is copied
perhaps two directly
let's increase the input complexity by
adding a second sample
[Music]
here we have the discrete simple tiled
method it has the right tiles
but not the right patterns
[Music]
now a 2x2 overlap
I think this is good for capturing the
feel of the original
but leaving variety
and finally a three by three overlap
overlapping wave function collapse can
also work with pixels instead of tiles
as you can see in Moxie's original
demonstrations
it's the overlapping method that ensures
a likeness to the original image
images with simple colors are easier to
work with
remember the modules should represent
some repeating component of the original
for complex images you might want to
consider other texture synthesis methods
3D overlapping wave function collapse is
possible but more complicated than its
2D counterpart most 3D implementations
use the simple tile method these voxel
buildings from oxim's GitHub are some of
the only 3D overlapping examples I could
verify
after module and constrain creation the
next step is to consider how cells are
picked before being collapsed and
assigned a module
model synthesis iterates over cells in a
linear scanline order
that means it collapses the first cell
then moves to the next cell as you can
see here
a 2d or 3D grid can be flattened into a
one-dimensional array which is sometimes
a useful optimization anyway and then
the algorithm just iterates through
those cells in order
of course there are multiple ways to
flatten an array
so you can iterate in a different
direction
that may be important to consider if you
use this approach
unfortunately this method can introduce
directional artifacts
this drove me crazy for a little bit
because I thought it might just be my
implementation
here Maxim's observations of the linear
scanline artifacts do you see them
depending on what you're doing this may
not be an issue but if it is wave
function collapse provides a nice
alternative
wave function collapse picks the cell
with the lowest entropy
entropy can be interpreted as a measure
of uncertainty
higher entropy means higher uncertainty
about what outcomes will occur
an entropy is zero means you know
exactly what will happen
consider these two cells
cell a has two options
Cell B has three
you might think the cell with the lowest
entropy is the one with the least
options or the smallest domain
that's a useful approach but we can go
farther than that
entropy not only considers how many
modules are in each cell's domain
but also How likely each of these
modules are to be selected
let's add weight to the modules
these can also be converted to relative
probabilities
if all the modules are equally likely to
be selected
then the cell with the lowest entropy
will be the one with the smallest domain
however what if we're in a ruins biome
where the old tile pathway is very
common and the bushes and flowers are
very rare
let's give the pathway a weight of 9 and
give both bushes and flowers a weight of
one
cell a has two equally likely modules
there are only two options but it'll be
hard to know which will be selected
Cell B has three options
but the pathway is much more likely to
be selected
this cell has more choices but actually
has lower entropy so this is the cell
that should be collapsed first
while it takes a little longer to
calculate entropy than it does to
calculate domain size
in my experience lowest entropy is still
pretty fast
the lowest entropy approach is also fun
to watch
for me this is a big part of the charm
of wave function collapse
while we're talking about weights both
model synthesis and wave function
collapse can use a weighted random
selection method to pick a module from a
cell
[Music]
I really like that adjusting the weights
can give such a different feel to
generation
for this tile set a few adjustments can
shift generation from forests and
grassland
to ancient ruins
[Music]
for the propagation step which is the
slowest step
both model synthesis and wave function
collapse use a standard constraint
satisfaction approach called Arc
consistency
to be brief this involves removing
modules from a cell's domain if it does
not match with one of the possible
modules in an adjacent cells domain
you may recall that we already discussed
the constraint propagation step since
there are no major differences in how
model synthesis and wave function
collapse handle propagation I'm going to
skip ahead to talking about generation
failures if you want to learn more I've
included some links in the description I
highly recommend Boris the Braves
explanation of Arc consistency
let's talk about failure yes it can
happen as you can see here
failure to generate something that
satisfies all constraints is a
possibility for both model synthesis and
wave function collapse
it's possible for the propagation step
to remove all modules from a cell's
domain this is what happened in the last
generation
failure becomes more likely when using
large complex module sets as you can see
in this graph from Paul's dissertation
the top Castle set is much easier to
generate than the bottom escheresque set
especially as the generation size
becomes large
failure is actually a known challenge
for constraint-based problem solving
as this is an established issue they're
also established Solutions like simply
restarting generation completely or
backtracking to an earlier state of
generation and trying a different option
than before
backtracking is what you see here
wave function collapse leads you to
implement your own method to deal with
failures
but model synthesis also includes a
novel solution called modifying in
blocks or modifying in parts
in this approach we start with some
simple solution like filling the entire
grid with all grass styles
now we can start generation one block at
a time
instead of generating the entire map we
divide generation into smaller more
manageable blocks
first let's initialize this block
now we regenerate it if generation fails
we can start over with that block
without needing to restart the whole map
when we clear the next block you might
notice we cleared some of what we just
generated the blocks do overlap
they overlap so that cells On the Border
get constraint information from
neighboring blocks and the overlapping
cells can also be regenerated
we continue in this manner until each
block has been regenerated the sides of
the blocks and how much they overlap may
affect generation
there are a few considerations to make
Paul talks about this in his
dissertation
I believe the modifying and blocks
approach also reduces or eliminates the
directional artifacts that can be
produced by linear cell iteration
hear or mock themes comparisons between
the two iteration methods
now here are some of Paul's comparisons
the top image in each set is model
synthesis and the bottom is wave
function collapse
the artifacts here are much harder to
notice possibly because Paul used the
modifying and blocks method
with the right adjustments modifying in
blocks becomes a good solution
this clip is from Boris the Brave's
excellent article on modifying in blocks
as you can see he was successful at
solving the very tricky esteresque set
this might be the only way to
consistently generate large 3D objects
from complex module sets like this one
check out boris's article for more
information
Marion kleinberg used a somewhat similar
chunk-based approach to generate
infinite worlds
it's not quite the same but I think this
demonstrates the potential of this
overall idea
see the description for a link to the
write-up and don't forget to check out
Marion's Twitter for updates
[Music]
while I'm doing plugs Rob Lang also
shows a similar infinite generation
approach in his Clopper devlog I really
like this series and I found myself
pleasantly distracted watching a few of
his videos just trying to find a clip to
show you check it out
both model synthesis and wave function
collapse are great algorithms and both
Paul and Maxime deserve credit for their
contributions
many developers actually borrow aspects
from both of these algorithms while
adding a few features of Their Own
as for my projects I have a hard time
deciding between 2D and 3D generation so
I've made sure my code can handle both
I think I'll stick with the discrete
simple tiled workflow it seems to work
well enough for me and the overlapping
method while really interesting adds
another level of complexity that I'm not
sure I need
so far I like the lowest entropy cell
selection technique I don't have to
worry about directional artifacts and it
seems fast enough
I'm hoping to refine my propagation code
a little more and I do need some error
handling so I might try the modifying
and blocks approach later
it seems really promising but I'm gonna
wait until I have a few other things
worked out
in the next video I'll give a
walkthrough of my Approach and I'll post
my code online
some of this will be Unity specific
though the concepts are translatable to
other engines and languages
I might add new features later but first
I'm hoping to provide a stable
implementation everyone can play with
and hopefully some of you can make some
fun new things too
one more thing before I go I just want
to give a huge thank you to everyone
that watched my last video I was
pleasantly surprised and honestly a
little overwhelmed by how great the
response was it was just incredible
there were also a lot of really
thoughtful comments make sure you check
them out
I do read all of them and I keep notes
on the various things that come up like
I know I need to show you how to address
the patchy distributions of water in the
next video
and thanks for sticking around for the
delay between videos too I know it was a
little while I'll just say job
Shenanigans some of it was accidentally
self-inflicted and some of it was out of
my hands but I think that'll all be
rectified soon
anyway I'm looking forward to hearing
your thoughts and I'm really looking
forward to getting to know some of the
regulars make sure you do all the
YouTube things again to feed the beast
you know it gets hungry like subscribe
hit the Bell say hello to your father
and don't forget only you can prevent
forest fires and I'll see you next time
[Music]